ich habe letztens dieses Video hier auf
tiktok gesehen und ich dachte mir das
muss ich probieren ich meine ich habe
alle erdenklichen Möglichkeiten
ausgetestet um neues Essen zu bestellen
deshalb habe ich jetzt drei Würfel mit
denen ich einfach mal munter drauf los
Würfeln werde wir werden bei zwei
Restaurants bestellen geht drei Speisen
und ich glaube es kann nur interessant
werden weil ich weiß bis zum Moment wo
wir das ganze bekommen einfach nicht was
mich erwartet legen wir los wir schauen
uns erstmal die Läden an ich habe als
allererstes mal ein neues September
rausgesucht ein vietnamesisches
Restaurant nur noch eine halbe Stunde
haben die offen wir werden das so machen
wir bestellen und holen dort ab weil
sonst ist das wieder für verwirrend wenn
man das dann lieferad bestellen muss und
wir gucken einmal auf die Speisekarte
hier sieht man jetzt keine Nummern wir
müssen mal gucken bei den Fotos hat man
nämlich gesehen sehen wir schon genau
was wir suchen wir haben Nummern und
zwar nicht zu knapp von eins ist 83 ist
über 66 werden wir nichts bestellen
können alle Sachen die sieben vorne
haben oder so können wir einfach nicht
bestellen weil wir haben halten einen
Würfel der nur bis 6 geht ich rufe jetzt
einfach mal an und dann dürfen wir drauf
los ich bin sehr gespannt was wir
bekommen
runter hi Max ich wollte kurz was zum
Abholen bestellen ist das möglich
super dann würde ich zu Beginn einmal
bitte die 11 nehmen dazu noch einmal die
ganz genau und zu guter letzt noch
einmal bitte die 52
ja ganz genau 15 Minuten alles klar dann
bin ich da vielen lieben Dank
Tschüss bis gleich ciao ciao auf jeden
Fall schaut auf diejenigen die das auf
tiktok gemacht haben ich weiß nicht ob
diese erfunden haben aber es ist eine
coole Idee ich habe wieder ein
Restaurant Konzept gewählt bei dem ich
immer das gleiche Stelle immer chicken
Ticker Masala bzw Butter schicken
indisches Restaurant wir haben eins
rausgesucht das hat 280 Speisen auf der
Karte alles schön durchnummeriert von 1
bis 286 perfekt für unsere Challenge
wenn wir Pech haben bestellen wir z.B
nur die Nummer 41 die mango-soße wäre
gucken wir mal was wir bekommen diesmal
brauchen wir drei Würfel und ich nehme
wieder den Hörer in die Hand
ja hallo hier Max ich wollte gerne was
zum Abholen bestellen ist das möglich
super dann hätte ich gerne einmal bitte
die Nummer 33 genau dann die 156 und
noch eine weitere Speise gerne die 115
noch dazu
alles klar Ciao ich meine wir geben
glaube ich gerade so in 5 Sekunden mit
keine Ahnung 50 Euro und das und das wir
sind natürlich genug Leute um das Ganze
auch auf zu essen gerade eben habe ich
gehört Schweinebauch Fisch habe ich
wirklich gar keine Ahnung was ich jetzt
überhaupt bekomme kriegen das einfach
gleich bzw wir uns jetzt ab schauen wir
mal was uns erwartet vielen Dank danke
sehr dann noch einen schönen Tag tschüss
Serie Sachen die ich nicht zuordnen kann
43,70 €. das klingt nach ja zwei
Hauptgerichten einer Vorspeise würde ich
sagen da drüben ist auch schon das
andere Restaurant wir gehen mal auf die
andere Straßenseite
30,50 bestellt 30 € nur drei Sachen
vielleicht ist das Mittagsangebot wir
schauen mal gehen ins Büro und gucken
uns das ganze mal an zurück im Office
und wir haben die erste Bestellung schon
auf dem Tisch neu September ich gucke
mal nach die Nummer 11 genommen 2 keine
Ahnung ob das richtig ausgesprochen ist
Veganer Mango Salat mit würzigem Tofu
Karotte und vietnamesischen Kreuzern
unsere Vorspeise ist glaube ich einmal
das hier einfach mal rausge Teufel die
Sache hier genau dieses Ding hier ist es
das ist unser Gericht so sieht das aus
kostet 9,90 Euro schon ordentlich für
eine Vorspeise aber wir gehen mal rein
in die Masse
war richtig schön genau diese Reaktion
habe ich glaube ich auch erwartet
richtig schön frisch der hat so eine
leicht essighaltiges Dressing ganz
interessanter Geschmack Minze ist dabei
schöne frische perfekt für den Sommertag
die Mango so im Julian Schnitt wie so
ein Mango Nudeln wirklich perfekt der
Sommersalat möchte man gebe ich ihn
fertig damit ich rede bisschen ich
glaube Erdnuss ist noch dabei Zwiebeln
ich hätte mir nichts besseres bestellen
können sehr sehr lecker
weiter geht es mit bunther_lo
wow alter Schwede siehst du wie viel das
ist vor allem guck mal das alles und
noch eine Lage da unten sind wir mit
13,90 € dabei unglaublich ich muss das
probieren das lässt mich so krass an
aber wie saftig der auch ist
boah Alter dazu die Fischsoße so wie es
jetzt gerade ist bräuchte sich das vor
keinem geilen Brauhaus Schweinebauch
verstecken wir gehen an die Reisnudeln
mit der Fischsoße man würde das ja
niemals bestellen never weil man so dumm
ist und man sich denken ich kenne das
nicht ich mag das genau aber Alter wir
haben das einfach bekommen
die Fischsoße hat auch so eine schöne
Charakteristik lauwarm ist sie wirklich
also Reizungen sind wunderbar lauwarm ja
Schweine aus krank geil finde wie
perfekter geschnitten ist ja das sieht
aus wie im Restaurant auf dem Teller
auch hier wieder ein bisschen Minze
dabei die Reisnudeln sind wirklich
perfekt gekocht also die kleben nicht so
man kennt das ja nur man bestellt das
irgendwie wenn asiatischen Restaurant da
hat man so einen Block Reisnudeln ein
Block
da kommt bald was ist wieder so ein
Gericht wo man nicht so perfekt
beschreiben kann weil es so viele neue
Eindrücke hat aber genau das habe ich ja
gesucht warum müssen wir dieses Video
machen damit wir das Essen Gericht die
Nummer 52 Kaka Lounge und das
interessant ist wir suchen die Nummer 52
vergibt aber die Nummer 52
Spezialität so berühmt das sogar die
Straße in der das Restaurant steht
welche diese Scheiße zuerst angeboten
wird
dazu Erdnüsse interessant 17,90 wir
haben wieder die gleiche Fischsuppe hier
drin dürften dann wahrscheinlich
Reisnudeln sein ganz genau und hier drin
ist Chaka Lava wow was für ein
Farbenspiel dieser gelbliche Wolfsbarsch
jede Menge Dill oben drauf sehr ich
total interessant mit dem ganzen Bild
ansonsten ich dachte das ist der Spargel
aber das sind Lauchzwiebeln dann unten
noch ein bisschen Salat sehr sehr
interessantes Gericht
darf man sagen dass das eine massive
Portion ist über diese darf man das darf
man sagen anfangen ich habe manchmal das
Gefühl durch diese Take Away Boxen
checkt man gar nicht wie viel man da
eigentlich ist das ist auch gefährlich
eigentlich das hier ist das
vietnamesische Nationalgericht wie es
scheint ich gehe einfach mal hier rein
weil mich dieser Dill und so voll
interessiert bin ganz ehrlich so
geschmacklich erwarte ich jetzt nicht so
viel wie ich gerade bekommen habe
es schmeckt so grün wie es aussieht
immerhin
boah der Wolfsbarsch der ist richtig in
sich auf eine heißen Platte wird das
serviert ich kann das aber auch richtig
gut sehen in so einer großen Pfanne so
stirfreie mäßig so dieses Gericht es
schmeckt übel lecker es ist schön frisch
und so ist es nur interessant und ein
bisschen komisch für mich weil wolfsbar
steht das ist so auch von der
Geschmackspalette ehrlich unbedingt so
das klassisch vietnamesische Gericht
dass ich erwarten würde das ist ja
offensichtlich klassisch weil sie
Nationalgericht ist das andere hat mich
voll umgehauen das hier schmeckt
interessant safe auf seinem
daseinsberechnung aber es ist einfach
nicht so ein Schocker sondern es
schmeckt gut aber nicht besser als
erwartet auch ein sehr leckeres Gericht
aber ich glaube mein absoluter Favorit
man sieht es auch bei der Schweinebauch
der Mango Salat auch super schön frisch
das hier ist für Leute diesmal
ausprobieren wollen aber auch unter dem
Preis Gesichtspunkt 20 € dafür sind die
anderen bessere dir machen wir weiter
mit dem indischen Restaurant hier einmal
das Essen aus dem indischen Restaurant
wie gesagt nur 30 € 50 für drei Gerichte
das erste richtig ich habe bisher noch
mal rausgesucht heißt schicken Sixty
five und es wie folgt aus erstmal 8,50 €
dafür richtig viel chicken habe ich das
Gefühl ne wenn wir mal gucken all das
hier schicken schicken schicken schicken
schicken gut für die Games auf jeden
Fall an dieser Stelle wird es
Hühnchenfleisch mariniert in Masala mit
Paprika und Zwiebeln das andere
Restaurant so gut vorgelegt ne das ist
jetzt echt keine leichte Aufgabe aber
ich glaube hier sind wir gleich auch
sehr gut dabei probieren ja
butterweich sieht zwar so aus dürfte
aber für mich noch ein bisschen schärfer
sein das schmeckt ein bisschen
zurückgenommen von flavour bis
ausprobieren
ist schon lecker aber wunderbar zart
muss man echt sagen ich habe jetzt nicht
direkt schicken Ticker Masala den Kopf
aber es schmeckt ist auch Chicken Curry
am Ende des Tages oder ist aber auch
irgendwo nur eine Vorspeise deshalb ab
zum nächsten Gericht Panier buna Masala
hausgemachter Hüttenkäse mit frischen
Tomaten Zwiebeln Ingwer Knoblauch und
Gewürzen also das hätte ich auf gar
keinen Fall bestellt hausgemachten
Hüttenkäse ich bin sehr gespannt das ist
anscheinend dieser Hüttenkäse ich hatte
erst gedacht dass das vielleicht tofu
ist oder sowas ne es hat einen sehr
prägnanten süßlichen Geruch der hier
kommt dann liegt auch oben was drauf ist
ein bisschen aussieht vielleicht rechts
Zwiebeln oder so also es riecht halt
auch ein bisschen ich probiere jetzt
einfach mal diesen Hüttenkäse
schmeckt überhaupt nicht so kräftig
käsig sondern wirklich ja schon stark in
Richtung von tofu schmeckt ja so neutral
wenn er nicht stark gewürzt und der ist
klar
kräftigen würzigen Soße aber an und für
sich ist das relativ geschmackvoll die
Soße selbst einmal für den Erik
ich mag das auch gerne also es gibt
nichts daran dass mir nicht schmeckt
aber ich weiß ja nicht ob dieser Käse
meine erste Wahl wäre weil der fügt
nicht genau also der ist jetzt gar nicht
wie so ein Väter so der ist sehr sehr
mild fast so weich wie ein Mozzarella
gefällt mir gut jetzt bin ich gespannt
ob das Lamm Mango Curry schauen wir
jetzt mal unser Lamm Mango Curry an dass
du dumm Curry erwischt haben ne weil
irgendwie so dreimal ja obwohl das kein
curry ist aber das sieht halt Aussehen
Curry das andere war Curry ich hole die
Soße Mango interessiert mich
boah krass krasser Mann und ich frage
mich wie das jetzt zusammenpassen soll
mit dem Namen würzig kräftig und das ist
eine echte süße das schmeckt schon fast
ein bisschen wie so ein Mango das Ziel
geil aber geil ist drin
zumindest so vom ersten schneiden
der Garten vom Land ist leider nicht so
gut getroffen also ich finde das
schicken war deutlich besser richtig
schön saftig das Lamm ist jetzt ein
bisschen zäh passt aber geschmacklich
überraschend gut zu dieser Soße also
dieses kräftige schon fast ein bisschen
stallige so vom Land das schmeckt super
gut mit der mango-soße gerade vom Preis
Leistungspunkt her wir haben 30 € 50
bezahlen der heutigen Zeit für diese
drei Gerichte crazy was haben wir heute
gelernt dass ich mal wieder gelohnt hat
etwas Neues auszuprobieren wirklich das
hat so Spaß gemacht von Anfang bis Ende
zu bestellen abzuholen zu probieren und
neue Sachen kennenzulernen dass man
leichter wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
werden wir bestimmt noch eine Methode
ein Essen zu bestellen wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Video wieder bis dahin
mach's gut ciao